vous souvenez-vous de la première fois que vous avez vu un
dinosaure et que je suis avec du bleu, elle
manifeste un souci d'intérêt vous
souvenez-vous de la première fois que vous avez vu un
dinosaure pour les enfants qui grandissent en aimant les
dinosaures, les films jurassiques sont vraiment
le moyen pour eux de voir leurs rêves se
réaliser  les films Jurassic ont toujours
été pleins de suspense et passionnants nous
racontons le prochain chapitre cette histoire
prend des dinosaures et emmène Jurassic là où
elle n'est jamais allée avant que
nous soyons littéralement en train de faire exploser l'île
dans ce film nous avons un nouveau réalisateur
Juan Antonio Bayona j'adore jouer  avec le
suspense
j'aime l'intensité et j'aime faire
ressentir au public l'expérience totale qu'il est
génial quand il s'agit d'effrayer les
gens visitez votre ex des dinosaures prudents
partout et ils s'effondrent et
tuent des gens allons-y c'était important
pour nous que l'histoire soit  équilibré sur les
personnages dont certains que nous connaissons et
dont certains venaient juste de rencontrer Jeff Goldblum
ne va pas mentir c'est assez génial
tu es qui je suis ta  À
nouveau à propos des dinosaures dans ce monde jurassique, vous
verrez plus de dinosaures que vous n'en avez jamais vu
auparavant sur ce film, nous avons affaire à de
vrais dinosaures animatroniques, il ressemble à
un vrai dinosaure, je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de
paniquer tout le temps le défi
de  faire une suite, c'est trouver le bon
équilibre entre ce que les gens
attendent
[Musique]
et ce qui les surprendrait
ce film est différent ça va être
intense et assez spectaculaire
[Musique
] c'était mon meilleur jeu
ça ne ressemble à rien de toi  'ai jamais vu
avant
ouais mec c'est du Jurassique
ça va être génial
[Musique]